- A lot of folks think that a librarian
is just someone who checks books
in and out of a library for you,
but that's not true.
"Librarian" is a highly skilled profession
that requires a lot of specialised training.
It's about helping people research
and access knowledge,
in whatever way makes sense.
Through the 20th century, that knowledge
was held in books and on microfilm tapes
stored in central buildings in each town,
like this one,
as a public good,
which is actually almost
miraculous when you think about it.
The modern public library
is a revolutionary, wonderful idea.
Knowledge and information
should be available to everyone,
not just the rich and not just the clever.
In the 21st century, that's still true.
A lot of that information
might be online now
and available through our phones,
but in-depth research,
searching out truth from fiction,
shouldn't be just for people
who are able to understand
complex academic citations
and referencing.
If you don't know how
to look something up,
if you don't even know really
what you're looking for,
if you don't have the words,
the librarian's job
is to help you find out.
In an ideal world that's what
librarians would be doing,
not pushing a cart and
moving books around by hand.
That's why here at Oodi, the
new Helsinki Central Library,
those books are being moved by a robot.
- This Oodi building was built last year,
so it's a pretty new building
and that's why we have
a lot of new technology
and new services in here.
It has been said that it's
like a living room for citizens.
So, for example, in the first floor,
we have a movie theatre.
Then, in the second floor,
we have things to do.
For example, 3D printers and laser cutters
and music studios, and even a kitchen.
You can play computer games.
We have VR classes there,
and gaming computers.
Oodi isn't that traditional library,
so in the third floor,
where we have our books,
it's not that silent space.
People can talk there freely.
And so, we have a few
classrooms for silent reading.
In normal big libraries,
there's usually some
kind of returning machine
that sorts the books to the right places.
We have also that here.
The customers can return
books from the first floor,
and they will come,
using the conveyor, to this basement
and they will be sorted
by genre and language.
That's pretty basic stuff,
but we are in progress
of further automating it.
So, we have a couple of robotic arms,
and then we have three mobile robots.
Those mobile robots
will pick up these boxes
and they will be transferred
by them to the third floor,
where staff can shelve the books.
Small part of books will be
shelved by our robotic arm
that will the put the books in shelves.
And when the shelf is full,
it will be transferred
by those mobile robots.
Then we have some plans
to use mobile robots
in nights to scan the books with
RFID antennas,
so we know if there's any books
in wrong places.
Those mobile robots that we are using
are planned so that they can
avoid collisions with people.
If someone gets in front of our robot
it will calculate new routes
and find another way to
get to the right position.
At least at this point, there
hasn't been any accidents
or things like that, so
the robots and humans
have been getting together very well.
And people are quite curious about them
and why we have them here,
and what they can do.
- This library gets a lot
of press for its robots.
There was even a design
prototype with googly eyes
that guided people to
the shelf they wanted.
But most people can read a
map or follow directions.
The real job of the robots here
is the same as robots everywhere:
automation.
Don't waste the librarians' time with
tasks that a computer can now do.
If you think public libraries are just about
collections of books then, yeah,
of course they seem outdated.
Public libraries in the 21st century
can be where you go to borrow a book,
that's not going to stop,
but libraries were never just about books.
They're about information.
Free at the point of use, no price tag.
They're about collaboration
and communication.
And about making sure that
everyone can find truth.
Most libraries don't have robots,
but every library does have librarians.
And they're what's important.
Thanks so much to all the team at Oodi
for showing me around.
Find out more about them
by clicking the link in the description.